foreign
the essence of philosophy is that a man
should so live that his happiness shall
depend as little as possible on external
things
people are not disturbed by things but
by the views they take of them
[Music]
a city is not adorned by external things
but by the virtue of those who dwell in
it
[Music]
he who exercises wisdom exercises
knowledge of God
[Music]
to accuse others of One's Own Misfortune
is a sign of lack of Education
to accuse oneself shows that one's
education has begun
to accuse neither oneself nor others
shows that one's education is complete
in every Affair consider what precedes
and what follows then take action
[Music]
those proficient praise no one blame no
one and accuse no one
difficulties reveal the character of men
[Music]
events happen as they do people behave
as they are Embrace what you get
neither call yourself a philosopher nor
talk among the unlearned about theorems
but act according to them
when anyone provokes you be assured that
it is your opinion that provokes you
lameness is an impediment of the leg not
of the will
be free from grief not through
insensibility like irrational animals
nor through want of thought like the
foolish
but like a man of virtue by having
reason as the consolation of grief
fortify yourself with contentment
this is an impregnable Fortress
it is better to do wrong seldom and to
own it than to do wrong often but never
admit it
keep your attention focused entirely on
what is truly your own concern and be
clear that what belongs to others is
their business and none of yours
most of what passes for legitimate
entertainment is inferior and foolish
and only caters to or exploits people's
weaknesses
death is nothing terrible else it would
have appeared so to Socrates but the
terror consists in our notion of death
that it is terrible
[Music]
he is a wise man who does not grieve for
the things which he has not but rejoices
for those sayings which he has
foreign
is free who's not master of himself
[Music]
what is the first business someone who
practices philosophy
to get rid of self-conceit for it is
impossible for anyone to begin to learn
that which he thinks he already knows
first say to yourself what you would be
then do that which you have to do
[Music]
since it is reason Which shapes and
regulates all other things it ought not
itself to be left to disorder
you can be Invincible if you never enter
into a contest that you cannot win
reason is not measured by size or height
but by principle
[Music]
nothing great is created suddenly any
more than a bunch of grapes or a fig
the origin of Sorrow is this to wish for
something that never comes to pass
freedom is secured not by the fulfilling
of men's desires but by the removal of
Desire
in theory there is nothing to hinder our
following what we are taught but in life
there are many things that distract us
the key is to keep company only with
people who uplift you whose presence
brings out your best
if you are in pain you will find
fortitude
if you hear unpleasant language you will
find patience
if you seek truth you will not seek to
gain a victory by every possible means
and when you have found truth you need
not fear being defeated
[Music]
decide to be extraordinary and do what
you need to do now
[Music]
suffering arises from trying to control
the uncontrollable
or from neglecting what is within your
power to do
[Music]
no matter what happens it is within my
power to turn it to my advantage
nothing is in reality either Pleasant or
unpleasant by Nature All Things become
so through habit
[Music]
things in our control our opinion
Pursuit desire aversion and in a word
whatever our own actions are
if you want to improve prepare to be
thought foolish and stupid
[Music]
attach yourself to what is spiritually
Superior regardless of what other people
think or do hold to your true
aspirations no matter what is going on
around you
foreign
freedom is the only worthy goal in life
it is one by disregarding things that
lie beyond your control
nature hath given men one tongue and two
ears that we may hear from others twice
as much as we speak
true instruction is this to learn to
wish that each thing should come to pass
as it does
we should not Moor a ship with a single
anchor nor our life with a single hope
had this thought ever present within
thee when thou loses stand the outward
thing what thou gainest in its Stead
when you are offended at any man's fault
turn to yourself and study your own
failings then you will forget your anger
everything has two handles the one by
which it may be carried and the other by
which it cannot
to you all you have seems small to me
all I have seems great
your desire is insatiable mine is
satisfied
he who laughs at himself never runs out
of things to laugh at
there was only one way to happiness to
cease worrying about things which are
beyond your control
[Music]
give me by all means the shorter and
nobler life rather than the longer and
baser one
if you ever happen to turn your
attention to externals for the pleasure
of anyone be assured that you have
ruined your scheme of life
seek not the good in external things
seek it in yourself
you are but an image and not the thing
you appear to be
[Music]
the Philosopher's School Yemen is a
surgery you ought not to go out of it
with pleasure but with pain
for you were not in Sound Health When
you entered
no man is able to make progress when he
is wavering between two opposites
foreign
s then proceed to the greater ones
my business to manage carefully and
dexterously whatever happens
freedom and slavery the one is the name
of virtue the other advice both are acts
of the will
You Are Not Alone nay God is within and
your Genius is within
foreign
anything else than the power of living
as we choose
first learn the meaning of what you say
then speak
circumstances don't make the man they
only reveal him
[Music]
of Pleasures those which are the most
common rarely give the most Delight
thank you
remember that you ought to behave in
life as you would at a banquet
a person capable of angering you becomes
your master
you are a little soul carrying a corpse
it's for sex abstain as far as possible
before marriage and if you do partake of
it do nothing that is socially
unacceptable
[Music]
foreign